Spain is famous for flamenco, the Pamplona bull running and bull fighting,...
...but what may be less known is that the world's biggest food fight is held in Buñol,...
...near Valencia, on the last Wednesday of every August.
30,000 people attend the festival called "Tomatina" to throw about 250,000 pounds of tomatoes at each other.
To start with, there is a ham on a stick competition.
Contestants climb a pole and bring back a smoked leg of ham stuck on it.
After this, people put on some eye protection...
...and big trucks deliver masses of tomatoes and dump them on the street.
People bombard each other with the tomatoes until all of them have been thrown.
This tradition goes back to 1945...
...when two young men got into an argument  and started to fight each other during a carnival,...
...throwing tomatoes from a nearby vegetable stall among other things.
Since then, the "Tomatina" has become an annual tradition.